[Music]
And you are watching I'd like to know
our Bible question and answer program
here at SumTV. And we are so very very
glad that you're sharing your day with
us. My name is CA Murray. I'm in the
company of Pastor David Salazar, general
manager of our Latino channel. Pastor
Steven Boore, president and founder of
this ministry. And we are glad that
you've joined us and that we get the
opportunity once again to answer your
Biblebased questions with Biblebased
answers. Easy for me to say. Um
>> and and we thank you for sending them
in. Again, as always, should you want to
get in on the fund, we encourage you to
do so by writing to us at tvsumtv.org.
That's TV at some suum as in Mary tv.org
and we will get to your questions as
soon as we can. We have the wonderful
problem of having many many questions.
That's a good thing uh for us and we
want more. We're we're a little greedy
that way. You've given us many, we want
some more. And we want to know those
questions that you have and we promise
you to give you Bible answers to each
and every one of your Bible- based
questions if indeed we can and an answer
can be found. Pastor David Salazar,
would you lead us in prayer?
>> Yes, absolutely. Let us pray. Heavenly
Father, we are so thankful that we can
come to you and to the um throne of
grace where you provide for us the
spirit of of of the Holy Spirit, the one
that can help us understand and remember
the things you have said, help us to uh
be able to discern discern the
scriptures and be able to share from
your word things that are true. So we
ask Lord that you will give us the Holy
Spirit now as we open your word. May we
give answers that are according to your
will. And even though we don't know of
ourselves many things, we know that
through your uh blessing, through your
power of the Holy Spirit, we can
actually give answers that will bring
people closer to you and to the
knowledge of your scriptures. Bless us
now as we open your word. We pray this
in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question comes
to us from Phillip. We don't have a
location but thank you sir very much
Philip for sending in the question.
Hello friends over and over again Ellen
White says that marriage and Sabbath are
twin institutions.
So my question is is it a must to marry?
Because when somebody reaches marriage
age and ignores to marry yet keeps the
Sabbath, it seems that person degrades
the twin uh to Sabbath which is
marriage.
What I would say to sort of take the
book out of the dock on this is marriage
and Sabbath are the two institutions
that came to man prein. They they come
with the blessing of God. Sabbath. Uh
just after Adam and Eve were created and
married by God, the first thing they did
was was keep Sabbath.
>> But they are not equal. They're not the
same thing. There are two institutions
that have come to us from a pre sin
time,
>> but they're not the same thing. They're
not equal and we should not look at them
as such.
>> So I want to start there and I see you
opening your Bible. I see you got your
Bible open. So you've got something to
say. So, I'll let you put your bean in
the pot and add to what what I what I've
started out here.
>> Well, you know, we have to look in the
Bible at
the concept or or what the
advice is by by some of the apostles,
some of the men that are inspired by God
in regards to marriage. We can
definitely see that marriage was given
at creation as a institution of a
blessing to the mankind. uh so that we
could have children. The earth could be
fulfilled and filled with children and
with individuals with men and women and
they would truly
have a earth full of servants of God,
children of God. Nevertheless, uh, as
sin came to the world and as we go
through the experience of the Bible, we
find, for example, in the book of
Colossians
or 1 Corinthians, rather, let's start in
1 Corinthians chapter 7, the concept of
Paul in regards of the principles of
marriage. Now, he spoke of himself as an
example of a of an individual who did
not need to be married in order to serve
the Lord. And he actually mentions there
that in verse uh you know one now
considering the things of which you
wrote to me it is good for a man not to
touch a woman. So he was trying to say
that there is a there's a good thing to
be able to not be married if it's
possible to fulfill your duty to the
Lord like he did. He had to travel
extensively. He had to be an evangelist.
He had to be a missionary and he
couldn't raise a family in that
environment. So for his role and his
calling to the apostilhip he was one
that in his experience he was not
married and he was able to perform that
work for the Lord better. In verse uh
seven for example he says for I wish
that all men were even as myself but
each one has his own gift from God and
one one in this manner and another in
that. So he makes it clear that marriage
is not necessarily for every single
individual and in the case of him he
thought that it was for his benefit not
to be married so that he could fulfill
the work of God better. And so we are
even though the institution was
established at at gen at creation even
though it was institution that one of
the two institutions that came before
sin it is not necessarily a requirement
to be married from the Bible as Paul
clearly said it about himself.
>> Yeah I like that if you enter into the
institution it has the blessings of God.
Yeah.
>> But it is not obligatory. You don't have
to be married. Uh and Paul says for me,
>> yeah,
>> doing the work of God, uh this would not
uh this would not work. In fact, he
gives the the the the implication that
it may be an impediment to what I want
to do.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh and I I I just want to dedicate. Now,
for some that works.
>> Uh but not for everybody.
>> Exactly.
>> Didn't for you,
>> didn't for you, doesn't for me, but it
it does work for some people. Some
people don't need to be married. Yeah.
uh because of the way they prosecute
their life and some people don't need to
have children because they're not
>> everybody can't parent. Everybody
doesn't have the patience to to to do
that kind of thing. Right?
>> So for some good for others
>> maybe not.
>> Pastor,
>> I think that in this period of human
history,
it's a very serious thing to have
children.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Yes,
>> because the world is so wicked out there
and there's so many bad influences
that unless you live way out in the
country and you're not exposed to the
evils of the city time after time after
time,
it's very difficult to bring up children
in such an environment. Mhm.
>> And you know Jesus himself uh said that
when this time of trouble comes which we
see the world moving to very quickly. Um
in Matthew chapter 24
and uh verse 21 he says for then there
will be great tribulation such as has
not been since the beginning of the
world until this time no nor shall ever
be.
>> And unless those days were shortened no
flesh would be saved. But for the
elect's sake, those days will be
shortened. And then he says, "Woe to
those who are with child."
>> "And those who nurse children."
>> Yes.
>> In those days. Extremely difficult. Now,
I think there's something more serious
uh involved than what this person
expresses in the question.
>> And that is changing God's original
plan.
It would be a very serious matter to
say, "Well, we're going to keep Sunday
instead of the Sabbath."
>> Yeah.
>> And it would be very wrong. It would be
changing God's institution to say, "Um,
well, it's okay for a man and a man to
be married and a woman and a woman to be
married."
>> God is saying, "Don't change my original
plan."
>> Yes. which is for heterosexual marriage
and for the seventh day Sabbath
observance.
Um and yet the evangelical world is so
inconsistent
>> because they fight tooth and nail for
marriage between a man and a woman. I
mean they will say it has to be a man
and a woman. And you and you ask how
come? Well, because God says that he
married a man and a woman. So it has to
be a man and a woman. But then I ask,
what else did God say at the beginning
before sin?
>> It's the seventh day is the Sabbath.
>> So, how is it that you say that marriage
is still binding,
>> but that the Sabbath isn't binding
anymore? If both of them were created
before sin entered the world, right?
>> That's much more serious than whether
having children or not having children.
That's after marriage.
>> The important thing is to exalt
marriage. By the way, some women can't
have children,
>> right? So, are they being disobedient to
the Lord because they can't because they
can't have children? No.
>> And if a couple decides not to have
children because of what Jesus says here
in Matthew chapter 24, would that be off
base? I don't think that it would be off
base.
>> Yeah. And in in regards to the question,
pastor, uh you know, that the way that
he connects this individual connects the
twin institutions, it doesn't mean that
they're they're twin sense of you have
to keep both. You know the the
expression of nuite in regards to being
twin means that there's two of them that
were kept before sin came to the world.
Now
>> keeping the Sabbath is in the law of
God. It's the one that gives us the
identity, gives us a purpose of what we
are here. Uh it reminds us who our
creator is. And it's the day that the
Lord has sanctified, has made it holy.
Something we cannot change. and we must
worship the Lord on that day. Now the
marriage it's institution given for
mankind for the blessing of humanity but
it is not mandatory for every individual
in the world to partake of or be part of
and that's why we have to be very
careful because you cannot say oh if I
can if I don't have to get married well
I don't have to keep the Sabbath. No it
doesn't work that way. The Sabbath is
there's no you know because it's a
relationship between you and God while
marriage is a relationship that you
enter with another human being and if
you are not given the gift of remarried
or you are not called into that concept
uh you're not transgressing the law of
God at all you are uh you can still have
fellowship with friendships and you can
be uh like Paul was but it's not a
mandatory concept for every single
individual and that's why Paul mentions
there as as I read you that it is in
verse 8 for example about I say to the
unmarried and to the widow it is good
for them if they remain even as I am. So
some individuals can and should be
single for the work of the Lord and if
they can keep themselves pure but verse
9 it says but if they cannot exercise
self-control let them married for it is
better to be married than burned with
passion. So it's important that we keep
this in mind you know that there is that
marriage is a is a is a is a what was it
called is a possible a scenario for for
the world is an option let's put it that
way but it's not a must for every single
individual while they're keeping the
Sabbath it is for everybody
>> by the way both of these institutions
are illustrations of the relationship
between God and his people
>> right
>> marriage is a sign,
>> oh yes,
>> of the relationship between Christ
>> and the church,
>> right?
>> And the Sabbath is a sign of the
relationship between the creator and his
creatures.
>> So what gives you the right to say
marriage is a sign of the relationship
between God and his people, but the
Sabbath was for God's relationship with
the Jews.
>> That doesn't make sense.
>> It doesn't make any sense, right? Uh the
fact is that God created both of these
institutions at the beginning before
sin.
>> They're part of God's original plan.
>> Amen.
>> For the human race. And to say that I'll
choose one and I'll reject the other
just doesn't make any rational sense.
Yes.
>> And furthermore, it's not biblical.
>> Yes. Yes. I I want to thank you and this
is one of the reasons why I like this
program because you both have
articulated nuances to this particular
question that my mind did not
countenance I
the thing that jumped out at me is is
one if you want to enjoy the benefits of
marriage you got to be married
>> the other thing is if you want to enjoy
the benefits of full fellowship you
can't do it on Sunday you got to do it
on Sabbath because God wants you to
worship in spirit
and truth, right?
>> And and they have to go together. Um,
but this idea that
>> the the religious world fights so hard
to strictly define what marriage is, a
man and a woman, and yet is so lax on
the Sabbath. Uh, what you just
articulated, pastor, uh, is a a nuance,
a little wrinkle that had not occurred
to me, but it is very, very true.
>> How can you lean so hard on one, Pastor
David, and then be so slack on the
other, right? Uh they both come with the
blessings of God. They both come prein
and they both come
unalterable. You can't you can't change
them. You can't milk them. You can't
massage them. You can't you can't tear
them apart. They come
>> predefined.
>> Yes.
>> And and and it's sort of
you don't have to add water. It's
pre-made. It's ready for you. This is
marriage.
>> This is a Sabbath. And there is no other
reality that meets those requirements.
Mhm.
>> And if you try to, you are adulterating
what God originally put forth. And and
well said both of you. That really uh
that helped me out quite a lot.
>> Um time for just one more.
Let's see. This comes from R U. We don't
have a place. Hello pastors. Thank you
for your program. My question is
Zechariah 4:14.
And maybe we ought to read that, but as
you look at that, you're going to have
to read some more than 4:14 to get
context for that for that uh that
particular thing. And Revelation 11:4,
>> what are the anointed ones here? Are
both passages talking about the same or
or one talking about angels and the
other one Bible? Appreciate your reply.
Many thanks in advance. Um, this is
going to take a little unpackaging
because you can't just pull 414 out of
this whole scenario where Zachariah is
heading here and have it make sense. You
really got to start at the beginning and
and Tom's not going to allow us to read
all of this. Um, and then go up to 14
and then you get the context for what
he's saying in in verse 14. But let's
read let's start at verse I'll start at
verse Oh my goodness. I'm trying to go
back and see where I can pick this up
and put a little comma here. Okay.
Moreover, let's start at verse 8.
>> Okay.
>> Moreover, the word of the Lord came to
me, saying, "The hands of Zerubbabel
have laid the foundation of this temple.
His hands shall also finish it. Then you
will know that the Lord of Hosts has
sent me to you. For who has despised the
day of small beginnings? For these seven
rejoice to see the plum line in the hand
of Zerubbabel.
They are the eyes of the Lord which can
which scan to and fro throughout the
whole earth. Now this is verse 11. Then
I answered and said to him, "What are
these two olive trees at the right of
the lampstand and at the left?" And I
further answered and said to him, "What
are these two olive branches that drip
into the receptacles of the two gold
pipes from which the golden oil drains?"
I'm reading from the New King James.
Then he then he answered me and said,
"Do you not know what these are?" And I
said, "No, my Lord." Now, here's the
verse that is in question. So he said
these are the two anointed ones who
stand beside the Lord uh of the whole
earth.
>> So if you just look at these are the two
anointed ones, you're wondering what are
the anointed ones? Who are the anointed
ones? Are they angels? Are they devil?
Are they real? So we're dealing with the
reconstruction of the temple and uh
those people and things that appertain
to the reconstruction of the temple. Um
there were those who were older in their
faith who didn't really like what was
going on, didn't appreciate it what what
was going on. And uh the Lord gave
certain individuals
uh the responsibility for construction
and that's what we are dealing with
here. Who wants to pick it up?
>> Well, we could say um thank you pastor
for for reading those verses. Um the
question it's interesting enough that
the question of verse 13 where the
messenger is asking the prophet do you
know what these are is also asked in
verse five
uh or you know in other words the the
concept is do you know who these olive
trees are? Do you understand what they
are? And in the first five he doesn't
know and so he answers them with what
you read. But then in this second part
again it makes reference to these trees
and gives the the the like this the
concept there. These are the two
anointed ones. So these olive trees that
he saw in a vision are considered by the
Lord as the two anointed ones. Now in
verse six,
it's interesting that as he's answering
the same question, who are these in
these two trees, it says, "And so he
answered and said to me, this is I'm
reading verse six. So he answered and
said unto me, this is the word of the
Lord to Serubbabel, not by might nor by
my power, nor by power, but by my
spirit, says the Lord of hosts." So here
we speaking, we're seeing that these
anointed ones are anointed because they
have the Holy Spirit, the spirit of God
that is the one that speaks, the one
that that that shares, the one that is
the one that is being emphasizing.
Therefore, just in the context of this
chapter, we can conclude that these
anointed ones, these this these uh olive
trees are symbols of the word of God
that is being moved by the spirit of
God. Therefore in connection to
revelation as the question was asking as
revelation 11:4 where you have the two
witnesses these are uh just u another
another symbol of these same
olive trees meaning the word of god the
bible the new and the old testament this
is how um I particularly have understood
this passage to be I don't know if
pastor bore has another interpretation
of these two olive trees But this is to
me how this re, you know, the the vision
is very clear. He's speaking of the word
of God as the one being anointed by God,
by the spirit of God.
>> It's significant that in Zechariah
chapter 4, you have only one lampstand.
>> In Revelation 11, you have two
lampstands. M
>> so the question is why would there only
be one in Zechariah and two in
Revelation
>> simply because the two lampstands
represent the Old and New Testament. And
when God showed Zechariah the vision,
there was only one testament, the Old
Testament,
>> right?
>> You know, the the Bible speaks the the
the Bible speaks of the scripture in
>> Tusums.
>> It's a two-edged sword,
>> right? Old and New Testament. There are
two lampstands in Revelation 11 which
Ellen White clearly identifies as the
witness of the Old and New Testaments.
There are two witnesses of the Old and
New Testaments.
>> Um you have two candlesticks,
two witnesses,
Old Testament, New Testament. Now I want
to read a statement from Ellen White
which puts it all together. Mhm.
>> This statement is found in testimonies
to ministers page 510
where she wrote this.
>> From the two olive trees, by the way,
there are two olive trees provide the
olive oil,
>> right,
>> to the lamps.
>> So the trees have olives and from the
olives comes the oil. So it says, "From
the two olive trees, the golden oil was
emptied through golden pipes into the
bowl of the candlestick and then into
the golden lamps that gave light to the
sanctuary." Now comes the application.
So from the holy ones, who are the holy
ones? They're the angels.
>> Yeah. So from the holy ones that stand
in God's presence,
his spirit, which is the oil, is
imparted to human instrumentalities
that are consecrated to his service. So
you have the two olive trees. They're
pouring oil into the receptacle.
Then from the receptacle, they go
through the pipes to the angels. And
then through the ministry of the angels,
they go to human beings to diffuse
light. She continues saying, "So from
the holy ones that stand in God's
presence, his spirit is imparted to
human instrumentalities
that are consecrated to his service."
The mission of the two anointed ones,
those who are standing in the presence
of God, is to communicate light and
power to God's people.
It is to receive blessing for us that
they stand in God's presence.
As the olive trees empty themselves into
the golden pipes, so the heavenly
messengers seek to communicate all that
they receive from God. The whole
heavenly treasure awaits our demand and
reception. And as we receive the
blessing, we in turn are to impart it.
Thus it is the holy lamps are fed and
the church becomes a lightbearer to the
world.
>> Amen.
>> So God has a chain. The chain is from
the olive trees. The oil
>> the oil is then given to the angels.
>> The angels then bring the blessing to
human beings
>> and human beings are to shed the light
to the world.
>> Amen.
>> And in the times of Zechariah there was
only the Old Testament scriptures.
That's why it's on.
>> But in the New Testament, you have both
the Old and New Testaments which are
represented by the two witnesses that
are there.
>> Ellen White makes it so simple.
>> Yes, indeed. Lord,
>> that's why the spirit of prophecy is
such an invaluable tool. Amen.
>> We have in the church. It it it just
blows away so much of the smoke that
surrounds some of these things that
makes things perfectly clear. Again, our
time is slipped into eternity. Allow me
in closing to wish you both grace and
peace through our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ. We'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye and God bless.
[Music]